[Music]
the screen junkies show with how Rudnick
hi Internet so the holiday movie season
is in full effect I can't wait to see
zero dark thirty so I can find out if we
got bin Laden I want to see Django
Unchained so I can count how many times
they use the n-word and Les Miserables I
want to see Russell Crowe saying all of
his movies should be musicals also
hopping into the fray is one of my
favorite filmmakers Judd Apatow with
this is 40 they invited us to attend the
junket and we don't handle junkets like
some of the other outlets we're not
gonna go in there and kiss their ass for
like five minutes
kiss their ass for like a minute and
then we do a bunch of fun stupid stuff
stick around you might end up seeing
them wax me you're definitely gonna see
them wax me hey guys it's great to see
you a huge fan okay but I thought there
was one thing that the movie was missing
actual 40s
oh the malt liquors yes we could create
this is 40 drinking game do you have I
mean how are your packets yeah are we
allowed to do that I'm gonna have a
party in my whole life I like drinking
is allowed on the internet I'm gonna ask
you guys trivia about yourselves if you
get the question right I drink you can
get it wrong you try good Cheers Ohio
what was your name of the Freaks and
Geeks episode that you guest-starred on
and something peanut something drank it
was called choking and token I named
three men that your wife has kissed on
screen Paul Rudd Owen Wilson and Matthew
Broderick Wow no delay I get a real pull
Paul you know according to your IMDB bio
what are your trademarks cockney accent
and a glass eye
nothing [ __ ] related your Loki sardonic
sense of humor and your deadpan delivery
whoa look I think I exhibited that with
my witness which of your films have full
frontal male nudity wanderlust
and walk hard right Forgetting Sarah
Marshall yes also acceptable so you have
to do it again Leslie what song did you
dance to Anna nail-polish commercial um
it was kiss but kiss my friends may feel
free to drink how many of your films
have pot in them oh that's gonna take a
while hey let's just both drink to that
huh yeah that's a that's a lot let's
taste really good on my sore throat okay
you guys are way too good at this let's
ratchet it up let's pay homage to one of
the best Apatow moments of all time the
waxing scene from 40 year old virgin
would each of you please lastly yes yes
are you serious would you ask me oh yeah
great put it up on my new year I say
we've done we did this exact same thing
with Wolf Blitzer it's are you crazy
just slap that on my leg as hard as you
can and rip it off yes you're gonna slap
that on me and then rip it off
we're getting this enough I have the
strength oh yeah Pickler slap it on real
good cookies Taylor Hicks wow yeah let's
do this for screen junkies yeah
Ruben Studdard is so much hair onion
look it doesn't even oh oh use that good
this barely made a dent
Oh daddy now watch me glue and come
ahead oh I'll never shave this leg again
you should actually I should I really
should to answer your questions yes it
hurt and yes
I threw up in Leslie man's purse really
sorry about that Leslie oh yeah and this
happened you're the best name ever Hal
red dick oh that couldn't be like a
better name
Hal Rudnick I might use that in a movie
I'll run the kill oh I'd be honored wow
that's pretty cool but you know even
better if they used me in one of those
films I've got great range
I could play Seth Rogen's robot pot
dealer let's roll a fatty
I could play Jason Segel super horny
pirate roommate argh
I heard you hooking up with a girl last
night in your room I listened through
the wall and jacked off with me hook or
I could do this so what's up Jud balls
in your court
watch this fully exposed in your movie
tweet at it hey did you guys see the
Hobbit this weekend my favorite part was
the Star Trek trailer what's your
perfect casting for JJ Abrams next
generation reboot Picard data Geordi
LaForge I don't care
funniest answer gets a screen junkies
t-shirt you want to win a t-shirt leave
a comment click share subscribe thanks
for watching on how ironic bye bye I'm
here with Christopher Dennis the most
famous Superman in Hollywood so how many
total figurines you have in your
collection I've got over 55,000 pieces
shut the [ __ ] up